hi everybody we're back to a segment we  do every week now ranking every  every trope that has ever ever happened  ever quick recap we got uh magic crabs  up top number uh  s oh right right this is the trope where  the  the plane doesn't um  that there's problems on the plane  pretty common trope  brian sanders does it i hate this trope  this is the trope where there's like  three houses next to each other it's  just not one of my favorite things to  see  a scary spider every time the spider  showed up in dune  i was really annoyed because it just  really uh distracted me  i will put that nest here though  cheeseburgers  d tier trains i'm i'm going to be on i  don't know this trope  i will probably put it a tier i'm just  going to put all the rest of the animals  in seats here  okay so that's that's uh this week's um  episode of every trope thanks um for  watching if you are  new to the channel i i can um  you